E aí
[Música]
em certa noite meu marido estava
jantando Como sempre ele estava bêbado
Oi e a cena não foi legal
ele tava com uma faca na mão e essa faca
ele batia várias vezes na mesa
ameaçando eu e meu filho mais velho
ele dizia repetir das vezes eu vou
acabar com vocês eu vou acabar com vocês
vou deixar apenas eu e a Laura que a
minha menina mais nova que é fruto do
casamento com ele
gente que sendo aquele momento eu olhei
e falei assim para mim mesma o que você
fez para chegar nesse ponto de suportar
tudo isso de aguentar tudo isso Cadê sua
auto-estima
e eu me deparei com aquilo meu filho
chorando meu filho desesperado com medo
eu me cogitava a possibilidade de uma
separação com certeza mas eu sentia
comido com a pandemia do corrigir 19
esses números ficaram estancadas
aumentaram demais o número de violência
doméstica adesivo as pessoas não saírem
de casa e fica esse convívio diário hoje
ficou insustentável para outros amigos
para muitas mulheres o levantamento do
Fórum Brasileiro de segurança pública em
parceria com o decote feito a pedido do
Banco Mundial revela o aumento de 431
por cento e relatos de briga de casal
essas brigas foram relatados por
vizinhos em redes sociais de Fevereiro a
brinde 2020 certo dia eu consegui me
livrar dele e do Fundo de mim de toda
minha alma Aquela toda aquela mala o que
eu sentia dele e consegui colocar um fim
nessa história hoje crime a filha de 4
anos e meu filho recém adulto sozinho
sem ajuda financeira do meu ex-marido
paga aluguel água luz todas as despesas
de casa E nessa com anemia eu tive que
procurar ajuda de uma cuidadora para
cuidar da minha filha para poder
trabalhar e dar meus cursos seguir minha
vida profissional tive a oportunidade de
conhecer através de redes sociais
mães empreendedoras que tinham a mesma
dificuldade do que eu assim como eu elas
precisavam conquistar a independência
financeira para conseguir outra
realidade hoje além depiladora designer
de sobrancelhas professora mãe de dois
eu ajudo outras mulheres a conquistar
sua independência financeira de um modo
geral é muito difícil porque quando se é
mãe esse desafio triplo e você não
precisa aprender o seu filho enquanto a
criança está lhe pedindo leite às vezes
dormindo você trabalhamos quietinha ali
para não acordar então assim é muito
difícil por isso que é importante uma
rede de apoio você que está assistindo
se possível os uma dos empreendedores
das empreendedoras das empreendedoras na
pernas e isso faz toda a diferença a
revolução do mundo pode ser feito de
acordo com a forma que você escolhe das
calças dinheiro e você é mulher que está
sofrendo de algum tipo de relacionamento
abusivo que às vezes está apanhando que
tá sofrendo com isso eu sinto muito
sinto muito mesmo não perca a esperança
procure ajuda de uma outra mulher tem
que conversar se você não sentir
confiança em ninguém
livros entender se você tenha questão
financeira e não consegue muito longe o
empreendedorismo posso-te salvar ele pó
o que foi que aconteceu comigo e quando
eu digo empreendedorismo eu não digo a
respeito de ter um escritório com 3
funcionários não passar um médico na
equipe de coisas não Eu quero dizer para
você que às vezes lá uma lata de leite
condensado é o chocolate para fazer um
brigadeiro um bolo para você vender já é
alguma coisa e pode te salvar trabalho
com reserva de emergência mas
principalmente busque ajuda em outras
mulheres como eu fiz e como eu estou
fazendo Atualmente as mulheres que estão
próximas de mim a vergonha é terrível a
vergonha de estar nessa situação eu
senti muito isso mas isso pode custar
tua vida enquanto você sentir essa
vergonha eu queria pedir ajuda pode
buscar a sua vida e a vida dos seus
filhos tenha confiança em você Peça
ajuda obrigado